oh yeah and then never said when we were in
Morocco yeah there was the dogs and then there
was a lot of cats and so then we would be doing
a scene and then Cat Cat and then the dogs were
just like but the thing is what do you think
happens when we die Keanu Reeves I know that
the ones who love us will miss us what is
your secret for always staying down there
forever well I mean gravity movies have made
so much money three and a half billion dollars
entertain entertain right yes because this is a
big deal for me right it's my name it's my name
and I literally go to the ocean and you scream
it's what is the she'll tell you your name is
Chuck Spadina there you go why don't we just call
you Casey Reeves my heart got your wounded stuffed
slings and arrows huh I think that's an error
wicking the whole time and the whole shebang
in 4d in VR an incredible drama you gotta put
a movie together stuff even though you counted
absolutely sometimes it just gets tough but
yeah we're hoping that we got high hopes for
[Music]
speed hot-air balloon yeah well it wouldn't
be called speed it would be called no drop I
don't know yet I haven't worked it out I was
just spitballing one of those like you know
those vans that they take the elderly around oh
yeah yeah I'm driving Danny's driving because
I don't remember where I am where are we going
when I scream you should I'm driving now we're
just old we're just all the people old modernized
we're like a fine wine this film doesn't have a
lot of physical action in it is that harder to
play for you or easier yeah it's not harder we
took my parent yeah so we kind of went the other
route and instead of my parent yeah there's the
arms my parent there are a lot of birds in the
movie we didn't harm it you say that it might
be a classic is is it's really nice we hope so
I mean you never know right but I mean we just
hope people like what we're doing anyway anyway
anyway it's really nice to hear him thank you
for sharing that but you just call Stardust baby
I know that's it I was there how was your travel
agent there's like new selling drugs tonight
Medina is what I look like hi sir were lost
they're soaking wet soaking wet yes and one of
the women in the film is married to the director
Eli Roth yes it's wife yes and you have a very
explicit sexy letter yeah very was that more
uncomfortable then then they usually are oh not
for me to make like every day like I can't wait
okay okay you're right yes yes sometimes you're
just shooting guys twice in the head yeah you
got to make sure then if I get thrown off of
something then Jackson does his thing good if
you want it to but you just want no one kicking
boy no yeah I could get hit by a car but you know
hospital he's like or you can hit by car once
one we gotta go yeah last film book that's it
yes did like to fight on a horse it's fun does
that not make this at all bad it's a little big
but the horse but the horse is real you could get
you could get thrown and trampled yeah you can
die but the thing is let's go that far but yeah
that's true come off the saddle you're supposed
to fall under it held onto the pommel excuse me
it's fine and then shoot someday but complete
damsel in distress and excuse us for a moment
I'm obviously didn't know I had a crush on her
I can't believe you both had crushes
on each other and you you were so
scared we were working well I know but
well what's such a wonderful person
I kind of want to walk yeah no she's not
she's not here but the balding pudenda
Zenda what is that oh wait do I want to know
what this there was once a time when John wick
realizes that half of the dog population
would dusted out a ton of this snap oh my
gosh what's your favorite me in the easy
my favorite me yeah of yourself I'm know
I'm not really familiar with my memes I know
it's a great statement what they just said
yeah okay you play the games what no they
sat on your head yet Oh cock-a-doodle-doo
really bad things for corner how
many tickles does it take to make
an octopus laugh tentacles fever
fever you know let's go that's my
mother I'm stealing it thank you
is really going to be breathtaking
[Applause]
all breathtaker you do what you
won't you County waves [Applause]